le 18 décembre dernier jean pierre
pernaut décidé de quitté de son propre
chef le confortable siège qu'il occupait
au journal de 13h de tf1 depuis
maintenant 33 ans
merci je vous aime je ne l'oublierai
jamais une place qu'il avait fait sienne
pour les très nombreux français qui
chaque jour se donner rendez vous à 13
heures est invité dans leur salon le
célèbre journaliste
bonjour à toutes et à tous j'espère que
jean pierre pernaut qui durant trois
décennies a su redonner ses lettres de
noblesse à nos régions et séduire les
français
on sera en direct avec vous dans les
régions mais si on peut le retrouver
chaque week-end sur lci beaucoup veulent
savoir quels seront ses prochains
projets comment l'homme appréhende sa
nouvelle vie des questions auxquelles
jean pierre va nous répondre tout de
suite sur notre plateau merci merci jean
pierre jean pierre samedi 9 janvier
c'était la grande première sur lci
l'émission hebdomadaire jean-pierre et
vous c'est diffuser de 13h45 à 14h40 ça
très très bien me marrer bravo à
philippe thuillier d'ailleurs voilà
thierry thulliez d'ailleurs c'est le
producteur exactement à thierry thulliez
d'avoir mis cette émission à l'antenne
c'est fabien damiens le patron
d'exactement fabien et de l'ombre à ceux
ci et pour cette première on a retrouvé
ce qui faisait le succès de notre empire
les régions sans oublier quelques coups
de gueule dont celui qui voit la
regarder le tout début de l'émission et
jean-pierre et chaud
[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous je suis
vraiment ravi de vous retrouver sur lci
désormais vous le savez pour cette
nouvelle émission qu'on va inaugurer
ensemble une émission qui vous donnera
la part l'actualité c'est important mais
ce qui est important c'est d'avoir votre
sentiment sur cette actualité est donc
t'as poussé un coup de gueule sur la
première t'as pas pu tout empêcher
et c'est pour ça qu'on thèmes évoqués le
vaccin contre la copie de 19 regardez
dernier exemple en date à nice les
aiguilles envoyés par l'état ne sont pas
la bonne taille et voilà des aiguilles
trop petit il manquait plus que ça pour
compléter le tableau
bref pour faire un guide de 50 pages on
a été très bons pour vacciner on n'est
pas bon est ce que vous aimez qui pousse
des coups de gueule comme ça guillaume
moi j'adore je suis dans cette émission
on découvre un nouveau jean pierre parce
que mine de rien le trésor c'est souvent
la même mécanique c'était lancement
reportage lancement reportage avait pas
souvent des invités en plateau là vous
êtes avec une demande il ya des duplex
vous poussez toujours vos coups de
gueule en plus ça marche bien en
audience de plomb bravo c'est pas des
coups de gueule fédéraux marque c'est
simple non je dis que la vaccination a
mal démarré en france était une
catastrophe
même le président semblait même le
président s'est mis en colère ça a
démarré ensuite placé en train de
coincer aussi nombreuses mairies parce
qu'on manque de maintien comme dans
d'autres pays d'ailleurs parce que c'est
à castets invraisemblable cette histoire
donc quand ça marche pas on doit dire
que ça marche pas c'est par un coup de
gueule contre personne
oui bernard montiel et là on le retrouve
en plus en chef de bornes ce qui nous
vaut quand même toiture était seul au
journal et là tu le fais très bien parce
que c'est pas évident en plus de donner
la parole des distillats par chaque fois
donc ça donne une énergie nouvelle
et puis franchement ce qui est
formidable c'est tentant de te voir
comme d'habitude c'est gentil gentil qui
manquait tant que ça vous élaborez la
bande je lui pendant 19 ans combien ça
coûte
ça coûte c'est vrai oui nicolas et moi
j'avais juste une question vous attendez
cependant depuis très longtemps en
réalité parce que vous avez tenté des
sorties dans le journal qui vous ont été
reprochés là là on a l'impression que
vous avez jamais été aussi heureux mais
ça fait ça fait longtemps vous attendez
scandé moi j'y suis tout simplement
parce que non ça fait pas longtemps que
j'attendais ce rendez vous j'ai été
passionné par le trésor jusqu'au bout et
c'est vrai que depuis six mois avec
l'aide de nathalie on avait décidé que
je parte heures facile mois avant mon
arrêt donc je me le suis mis dans la
tête après j'avais hâte d'en finir bon
gars mais j'aurais été très émouvant le
passage de témoin avec marie sauf si on
avait tous les deux les larmes aux yeux
à la fin j'ai tenu à ce que ce soit elle
qui disent au revoir c'était son journal
quand je suis parti et c'est vrai
qu'elle a des audiences formidable
depuis trois semaines maintenant donc 14
justement on a fait un petit comparatif
entre les deux jt entre le tien et celui
de marie sophie regard des élus c'est le
6 janvier le jour de l'épiphanie déjà
dans beaucoup de familles on a tiré les
rois ce week end ce 6 janvier
surtout c'est l'épiphanie vu leur vous
venez peut-être chez vous de trouver la
fève dominique la gauche sans père m'a
rejoint pour faire le point sur notre
opération sos village on en revient à
notre opération sos village avec vous
dominique la grosse en terre bonjour
consommer ou dominique dites nous
combien d'annonce au compteur alertés
les pendant ce temps là à la bourse de
paris
45 ans après est en baisse à l'heure
qu'il est en bref un mois de la bourse
elle est en baisse - 0,9 pour cent d'un
après midi et demain je souhaite un très
bon après midi et je vous dis à demain
avouez qu'elle quand même beaucoup plus
sympa que moi
le jt de 13h ou pas déjà qu'on sait lui
je regardais pas tout le temps donc là
quand je suis à la maison bien sûr c'est
celle que je vais regarder et non non
j'ai déjà trouvé aujourd'hui avec
plaisir parce que je les dis dans le jeu
il ya un membre de la faible c'est une
famille le trésor fait un groupe il ya
un membre de la famille qui s'en va
quelqu'un d'autre karim et c'est toute
l'équipe du journal qui est là les
correspondants en région sur les mêmes
et ils mettent toute leur passion pour
marie ciofi avec my so fixe et
formidablement intégrée elle va pas
bouleverser tout tout de suite elle va
faire évoluer le journal le veulent
moderniser sans doute un petit peu elle
moi je le regarde en tout cas avec
beaucoup de plaisir
tu parlais tout à l'heure de la
passation pouvoir on a envie de la
revoir regardez ces tests éclat
s'intéresse à rien marie-sophie c'est un
honneur de la tentation
et vivre ce moment avec toi avec les
équiper avec les téléspectateurs
et oui parce que tu seras là le 4
janvier tu viens de france télévisions
mais tu viens surtout deux franches
devrait regarder d'abord en la taxant la
garder un petit peu chaleur y en a
retenu comme disait qu'on devait le
garder
le gars de cela sinon on renie notre
coeur bon courage pour la suite
merci jean pierre je suis riche de tout
ce que tu viens de nous montrer ses prix
des notes mois depuis 2000
j'ai bien compris quelle est ma ma
feuille de route et si tu veux bien
eh ben il est bientôt lancer génériques
manon c'est vraiment touchant parce que
il ne faisait même pas regardé images il
était comme ça et je sais qu'il y ait
encore toi ça te touche énormément
j'aime toujours heureux de voir ça je
regrette qu'elle a très bien pris le
relais et que c'est une transition qui
s'est fait en beauté c'est rarissime à
la télé il ya eu la même entre camille
combal et et jean pierre foucault
on s'est amusé avec marie sophie un
petit une petite bande-annonce qui avait
castaldi et moi et moi il y aura
peut-être une passation de pouvoir
bientôt je te lis mais tu savais qui
assis avec ta fille regarde je suis dans
la famille pernaut la passion du petit
écran se transmet de génération en
génération
lou 17 ans s'imagine bien présenter des
émissions télé mais un peu différente de
celle de son père
être journaliste présentatrice télé way
en vrai c'est sympa ah ouais genre cyril
hanouna en france en vrai en fait c'est
stylé j'aimerais trop qu'un peu well
diriger une émission comme tpm pessah
pour être trop cool j'aimerais trop
c'est vrai qu'elle te contredis a fait
quoi est-ce que vendredi elle veut faire
les 20 premières minutes maison chômage
jusqu'à 20h l élection aurait alors et
maintenant je l'apprends mots je vais
lui faire faire une demi-heure de tpm
paix jusqu'à son chroniqueur et je pense
qu'on peut rigoler non mais on sera
chroniqueur de avec williams avec la
salle jean-pierre way et la cl de l2
regardez là en ce moment parce qu'elle
sait qu'on est là et battre
juste avant je voulais parler parce que
il ya elle le jour n'est donc il marche
très bien mais faut rappeler une chose
c'est que le format en parlerons du
format des lésions le format c'est c'est
votre forme à régler badr déposé on
parle on dit souvent que le format est
parfois plus fort que l'animateur aidant
à la preuve que les québécois la base
est bonne entre reprend les choses ça ça
continue à fonctionner entièrement nacho
père vous auriez été déçu si les
audiences étaient effondrés au quiz bien
sûr passage aux rites
on a tout fait pour que ça n'a aucune
raison que ça s'effondre marie sophie
aime les régions elle connaît bien ce
métier non c'est une femme j'étais un
homme on à 13 heures une équipe
formidable
on a une rom un format final on a
construit quelque chose qui était quand
je suis arrivée l'ancien journal de 13h
de tf1 était pas bon bon état avec na
avec mon logis que j'adorais mais
l'audience avait baissé il fallait donc
tous transformés on a transformé la
construit et dans mon livre qui sortira
l'on soit révisée en instance ne
l'oublié pas voir des trucs drôles dans
les ports et les bateaux déjà commandés
n'est pas sorti mais ce bon bref
dans mon livre je raconte comment on a
révolutionné le journal pour en faire le
produit qu'il est aujourd'hui c'est
aussi un produit se tient un format avec
des règles et puis il suffit d'aller
faire évoluer mais tout ça va évoluer
trade savent doit évoluer tout doucement
alors présentateur n'obtenaient pas
d'ici ainsi quand j'étais qu'il soit
posée parce que pour les téléspectateurs
j'aimerais qu'on fasse la chaude
jean-pierre la journée jean pierre
pernaut
quand il faisait les jt et maintenant à
quelle heure vous réveillez qu'on
faisait le jt 6h10 6h du matin alors
vous avez maintenant plutôt rude mais je
me suis en vers 9h30
c'est arrivé est ce que ça fait du bien
ça fait énormément de bien maintenant
j'ai un emploi du temps un peu plus de
temps qu ensuite à 6h new faisiez quoi
quand vous et le jt je me dépêchais
j'écoutais les radios les télés etc
là je continue fait quoi maintenant
dernière continue à vous jouer à la
playstation adopter un petit fifa n'ont
longtemps j'y joue au tarot sur mon
téléphone d'accord et puis après je vais
au bureau quand même parce que jean
pierre et vous ça se prépare pour le
ciel vous allez au bourg à quelle heure
maintenant
bonjour vers 10 heures le matin 9h30 sur
certains journaux vers certains jours 11
heures non c'est bien quoi suis je
vous êtes heureux oui très vraiment
c'est vrai bien des tripes et péter
velits le site internet il cartonne avec
les bourgs pour nom et puis à tf1 je
vais partir la semaine prochaine mais un
tournage pendant une semaine en alsace
pour faire un reportage qui sera diffusé
dimanche et à prix cassés
aucun regret alors dans son livre on
apprend plein de trucs à vous allez
rigoler qu'est ce que vous savez le
surnom qu'on donnait à jean-pierre quand
il était au lycée ont rappelé andré jean
pierre on l'appelait john paraît qu'on
vous appeler john parce que vous
ressembliez à john lennon à les déjouer
à vos débuts dans la rédaction de tf1
quels mots familiers péjoratif utilisé
les mauvaises langues pour qualifier les
équipes de jean pierre nous paraît connu
par où vous appelez les bouseux mais
alors tout ce qui faisait partie de
l'équipe de jean pierre muller vous dès
qu'on sortait de vouloir payer fait
qu'on était déboussolé pour sortir du
périphérique fait un reportage
il fallait mettre un casque de brousse
sauf pour aller au festival de cannes
rejoindre notre ami alors on y aller
festival de cadres les parisiens y
allait festival de deauville
sinon on allait pas en régionale et à
l'étranger sur les grands compliments
région n'avait jamais alors alors il ya
un humoriste qui a osé écraser des jeux
sur votre tête en pleine émission
oui c'est michel l'échelle au tournant
est ce que vous savez le cadeau qui a
reçu jean pierre pour son départ de tf1
rien reçu un cadeau et ouais je le dis
ici c'est une réplique de l'immeuble de
tf1 ouais en chocolat exactement
non vous inquiétez pas y'a pas de
chocolat
ils ont eut ils ont eu très très peur
non mais c'est vrai j'ai vu et on va
voir des images de votre mariage que
l'autre de votre mariage à chantilly
jean pierre et nathalie ont surpris ils
sont ils ont été surpris par un
paparazzi ouais c'est ça c'est quoi
l'histoire
non il ya un paparazzi qui avaient passé
la nuit dans l'église pour suivre les
paparazzi à l'époque et ça s'est calmé
depuis
maintenant les photos et met nous mêmes
sur les réseaux sociaux social voilà il
était car il y en a qui avaient passé la
nuit dans l'église et puis quelques
autres qui avaient essayé de rentrer
dans la soirée de mariage on les avait
un peu sorti c'est oui oui je sais pas
si il y'a que moi on chauffe c'est un
peu un peu un peu mer un gâteau au
chocolat pour 33 ans de jt a eu beau
cadeau qui j'avais plein de cadeaux
aussi pour mettre content il ya trois
ans on va pas recommencer des gros
cadeaux tombés d'accord sur et c'est sûr
on va voir les images de votre mariage
qu'on avait vu dans le dock regard
[Applaudissements]
aux premières loges de cette union
françoise la maman de jean pierre
disparu depuis
jean perret dans ton humour odeur très
très fier d'avoir de l'année comme bercy
ya quelque temps j'ai à beaune âge
j'étais gravement malade je peux pas
mourir tant que jean-pierre échelle
alors n'a évidemment je suis un petit
peu coincé parce que maintenant je
profite n'est plus seul mais je voudrais
[Musique]
irez vous lâcher plus maintenant tous
les deux là bas on se lâche pas depuis
vingt ans presque et puis ma mère a tenu
quelques années quand même elle a tenu
jusqu'à l'âge de 102 ans ça sent déjà
que vous avez arrêté le 13 heures
puisqu'elle était toujours regarder tous
les jours donc la foire est font passer
plus de temps maintenant avec va être
nathalie avec votre famille oui alors je
voudrais moi je pensais prendre le petit
déjeuner avec lui sauf que moi je me
lève très tôt le matin et lui dort
encore donc j'ai pensé que je fais mon
petit léger non on peut pas regretter
quand on prend une décision comme celle
là bas 60 et on pressent que 71 ans la
décision est vraiment très mûrement
réfléchi avec nathalie avec les équipes
de tf1 avec thierry thulliez et gilles
pétition dont comprendre on prend la
décision
on l'a mûri on l'organisent on a eu
quand même 3 la période quand même que
je raconte dans mon livre entre le 15
septembre quand j'ai annoncé à cause
d'une fuite on voulait pas l'annoncer
tout de suite mais une fuite dans le
figaro disant que j'allais partir il a
fallu le prévenir les équipes donc tous
les 3 mois 15 septembre 18 décembre
c'est un petit peu long quand c'est vrai
c'était dur cette période ouais c'était
un peu dur pour les équipes pour moi
pour les rédacteurs en chef du journal
pour tout le monde quand gérer at de
lancer la jpp tv sur internet j'avais
hâte de lancer l'émission lci
mais cela dit ça a permis à bail suffit
de bien s'acclimater de biens rencontre
de rencontrer tout le monde d'aller
faire le tour de france des régions de
voilà de s'imprégner de l'atmosphère que
j'ai créée dans ce journal et qu'elle va
faire évoluer de ce ventirad est ce que
depuis le passage de flambeau
marie-sophie vous a appelé on jouait
souvent rimé ce qu'elle vous elle vous a
demandé le premier jour j'ai faim j'ai
fait très attention de ne pas y aller je
ne voulais pas le 4 janvier que va
commencer je voulais pas être une sorte
de fantôme dans les couloirs les
l'applaudir à la fin du plateau j'aurais
eu des petits messages quand même la
veille en descente en fait pas une
équipe super donc c'est vrai qu'elle a
fait un très bon journal ce jour là et
tous les autres jours après et puis on
se voit on se bat il d'autres jours
square s'est dit qu'est ce que tu aurais
fait l'autre jour sur telle ou telle
histoire de la même chose que toi je
vais peut-être mais quel truc à telle
place même si ses pensées de la petite
polémique qu'ils ont que certains ont
essayé de lancer sur et vous avez suivi
c'est ridicule mais je suis parce qu'on
passe dessus ça le problème c'est
qu'elle n'est pas habitué encore à ce
genre de choses
fringe à la tronche pendant tout le
temps donc ça n'a aucune espèce
d'importance
est-ce que les gens maintenant vous
parle cause de l'émission sur lci où ils
vous font des commentaires sur le
journal de jt pour laszlo sur le journal
parce que le journal serait quand même 6
millions de téléspectateurs et les cci
c'est une chaîne d'info on est à 250
milles ou 308 donc c'est bien mais dont
il ya moins de gens quand même encore
habitent déjà habitués mais bon il petit
à petit ça va monter j'espère que ça
faire parler des gens dans les régions
là samedi on sera en montagne sur le
drame des sept chansons ordinaires et le
problème des personnes âgées isolées
dans les petits villages les personnes
âgées c'est épouvantable effet moi je
trouve ça je trouve ça fantastique parce
que au-delà des 30 ans qui ont été faits
dans ce gîte et c'est vraiment un
héritage que vous avez laissé et je
pense que anne sophie ne ferait pas
réchauffé par noman gentil c'est sa
cousine ne ferai pas la même chose
n'aurait peut-être pas cette même
authenticité et projet région si si ça
n'avait pas été fait avant et je trouve
ça vraiment formidable et c'est à tf1 le
seul programme qui est comme ça ça
apporte de la fraîcheur et c'est super
pour la chaîne jean-pierre il ya un truc
qui va donner beaucoup d'espoir aux
jeunes qui nous regardent c'est que j'ai
appris un truc dans le documentaire no 6
qui était sur toi c'est a pas eu mon
diplôme en diplomate et c'est pas fou
j'ai trouvé ça bon là c'est trop mignon
terminale cette immense rhin 17-18-19
fonctions physiques et aux traits 16 10
ans matt jean pierre préfère les
terrains de hockey aux salles de classe
le jeune homme ne décroche pas son bac
je faisais beaucoup de sport et c'est
vrai que j'étais pas très voilà je vais
manquer petit peu d'assiduité en
terminale en première et en terminale es
donc j'ai redoublé ma terminale pour
quelques petits points de rien du tout à
l'époque qui avait pas et pas 95% des
gens qui avaient le hac est en effet
moins beaucoup moins et j'ai fait partie
de ceux qu'il n'avait pas hemming est un
mot jp était à gauche continue en disant
que j'ai raté aussi une deuxième fois
après donc j'ai dépassé trois fois je
l'avais la troisième fois que maintenant
tu t'es jamais il tombe acquis non et à
l'époque on pouvait rentrer dans l'est
le journalisme libéré des obligations
militaires avec un niveau bac j'ai passé
le concours d'entrée j'étais le seul qui
d'ailleurs n'avait pas de licence à être
admis au concours d'entrée dont j'étais
contre guillaume j'ai une question pour
jean pierre vous avez passé 33 ans jt
tf1 maintenant vous êtes sur lci
on a l'impression que vous êtes
indéboulonnable de tf1 est ce qu on a
déjà essayé de vous débauchez et si vous
deviez partir ce serait où est ben
figurez vous que depuis trente trois ans
on n'a jamais payé de me débrouiller
ah oui non on n'a jamais essayé on avait
essayé un petit peu dans les années
précédentes quand la 5 est arrivé j'ai
failli partir sur l'a5
bon j'ai de la chance finalement ne pas
y être candidat que la catastrophe de sa
fermeture quand canal+ est arrivé on
m'avait proposé pierre lescure m'avait
proposé de rentrer dans l'équipe de
canal plus
mais je vous raconte une anecdote il
n'avait pas beaucoup d'argent à l'époque
qu'elle a plu j'ai voulu me payer avec
des stocks options et moi un homme de
terrain je ne sais pas ce que c'était
l'option attends je veux pas dire oui
donc j'ai dit non à un j'ai eu peur
parce que l'action de cabaye mille fois
plus laver suivante donc les jambes sont
rentrés sur préval ont gagné beaucoup
d'argent sur moi mais je n'ai pas
regretté du tout jamais je redis ma
pêche aurait dit [ __ ] j'ai suivi ce
groupe pendant quarante je suis rentré à
tefana 46 ans lavage connu toute la
période public a privé la télé ou en
noir et blanc les téléphones à fives et
s'est donc fait sympa vous regardez les
audiences de marie-sophie tous les jours
on pas tous les jours mais je sais
qu'elles sont très donne pas trop
carbone et sont aux alentours de 6
millions de téléspectateurs et 40 de
carentoir en part d'audience 2 % de part
d'audience qui reste ce qui est le cas
depuis un peu plus d'un an avec le vide
il ya une audience un peu plus fort mais
ça reste des audiences très très fort ce
qu'ils font mais c'est incroyable on va
j'aimerais qu'on voit vos adieux sur tf1
regardez ça a été le moment le plus
commenté et repris après 33 ans de bons
et loyaux services regarder après trois
ans avec vous on a créé des liens très
forts je dois vous dire que j ai mis
toute ma passion pendant presque la
moitié de ma vie où le savez c'est un
honneur pouvoir traverser la petite la
grande histoire du monde grâce à vous à
votre fidélité
donc j'arrête à moins qu'à mon âge on
peut avoir envie d'un autre rythme j'ai
une pensée pour ma femme qui était là
tout à l'heure pour ma mère qui pendant
trente ans on n'a jamais manqué
et je craque est là j'avais manqué le
journal non regarde sans doute de là
haut où je vous abandonne pas pour
autant merci à tous je vous embrasse du
fond du coeur merci je vous aime je vous
oublierai jamais non je n'aime pas
revoir ça c'était compliqué c'était dur
parce que j'y étais préparé mais le coup
de chez pas parler de ma mère ça va
c'est quand il m'ont fait plus tellement
de surprises dans le journal tous mes
copains
et puis avait patrick poivre d'arvor
aussi il y avait un mot de terre chazal
y avait un mot de tous les gens avec qui
j'ai bossé pendant pendant toutes ces
années et ça a été merveilleux ça a été
vraiment très très émouvant et j'étais
heureux et après les gens ont applaudi
pendant 10 minutes dans la salle de
jouques store le studio et dieu merci le
lendemain je partais en vacances avec
les enfants dont j'ai oublié tout ça
pendant quinze jours et man ray
complètement j'ai vu et je vais de votre
fils était un grand danseur wii avait
aussi vous êtes vous êtes plus heureuse
maintenant plus heureuse non mais c'est
toujours pareil heureuse mais c'est vrai
je suis soulagé je suis soulagé parce
que faut faire attention à sa santé
aussi c'est primordial il faut y penser
et non un journal physiquement ce
produit non menteur tu te levais tous
les matins à 6 heures du matin a su
rentrer tous les soirs tu disais qu'ils
étaient très fatigués et toujours pas de
ça ici un car les choses c'est normal je
veux dire à 70 ans me moi si je devais
me lever à 54 1 53 ans me levais tous
les matins 6 heures du matin je pense
que je serai fatigué le soir ce qui est
logique
donc moi je pense que son âge il doit
profiter un peu profité de sa famille
devenant je travaille davantage le
flotteur je travaille devant toi c'est
pas la même pression c'est non pas une
pression d'un trésor qui est très
compliqué à faire vous semblez vous
profitez plus qu'il a moins de pression
qui les parents qu'il a oui même le week
end
vous décrochez pas je suis sûr qu'on
vous faisiez le jt on décroche jamais
quand on présente un jean lassalle est
toujours en train de se demander on
parle avec un voisin il vous raconte un
truc vraiment ce qu'on va en faire don
jours ci c'est comme vous avez une
émission je parle avec un voisin
on essaie d'imaginer quel sujet on va
traiter comment etc
on écoute actu on écoute une radio on
écoute un journal on écoute et puis on
essaie à chaque fois qu'est ce que je
vais en faire dans le journal rien
quelque chose comment on va le faire
donc on pense sans arrêt au journal du
matin au soir